so people saw that i mean
even when they saw it that's kind of i
don't know
from my perspective that seems quite
brilliant this it seems like really
innovative that you would have code run
in the browser
it did impress me with something um
which i learned later about from eric
von hippel of mit which is
user innovation networks lead user
effects that
throwing out javascript even though we
weren't doing open source we were doing
beta releases early and
permissively with netscape getting early
developer feedback
absolutely critical i loved it i did
some of that with sgi with some of the
products i worked on but it really came
to the foreign netscape and that
you know culminated in mozilla where
you're dealing with developers all the
time and early adopters lead users but
the lead users helped to improve
javascript even in those
last few betas where i could hardly
change things i was under pretty rigid
change control
so we're talking about just a small
collection of individuals that are just
like
up front guy named bill dortch you can
find his work in the web archive still
from 1996. it's a single page
application it's an artist's gallery
of mountain art javascript it doesn't
quite work he uses javascript locally he
uses a local
database what you would think of now is
json but it's all
pure javascript code a bunch of objects
being constructed that's so cool
you